oh boy something i don't need after that
apple event is caffeine
but i'm gonna drink it anyway the apple
spring loaded event just ended i'm not
gonna lie
i'm pretty hyped first of all i feel
like this is an event that we've been
waiting for and
a lot of stuff was announced but let's
just get into it i want to cover a lot
of stuff
very very quickly one of the first
things that they did announce was that
they have a new apple card family plan
so that you'll be able to add other
people spouses family members
to your apple credit card so that
they'll also be able to start building
their credit there's a new layout for
podcasts which is very exciting because
my sister and i have a podcast if you
want to check it out i'll put a link in
the description it's called same brain
check it out if you haven't already it's
really cool they have some new
recommendations they also have a new
subscription plan which will give you
added benefits we also have a new color
of the iphone 12
and the iphone 12 mini it's this
beautiful purple color for spring i'm a
huge fan of the color purple so i'm
really excited about this
now moving on to air tags this is
something
that i feel like has been rumored for a
very
very very very very very long time for
years i feel like this is something that
we thought was going to be released at
every single apple event
and it hasn't but today is the day so
using the
find my network which i feel like i'm
never just i don't know
about the whole name of find my it's
weird
but it also works because it is exactly
what you're doing you're trying to find
your whatever
find your iphone find your friends and
now find your items
they're actually really cute and i think
one of the things that is kind of unique
is you're able to customize them with
emojis or text you better believe
i will be customizing the heck out of
my air tags i'll be putting these on
absolutely everything because i feel
like
i can't ever find anything like i would
probably lose my body if it was not
attached to myself
so this will work with any u1 device
like the iphone 12 and it uses precision
finding to guide you to the item it's
gonna be really funny
to see me walk around this house trying
to find items i'm thinking that we
should have
an air tag easter egg hunt get ready for
it
it's happening the price is actually not
too bad so for 29
you'll get one and for a pack of four
they are 99
orders will start friday and they're
going to be available on april 30th
which is so soon they also show these
hermes
leather accessories which are actually
really beautiful i don't think they set
a price on those because usually our med
stuff is
it's a little pricey this is kind of
exciting there's a big update to
apple tv 4k it has an all-new a12 bionic
chip and you can now play hdr and high
frame rate content which is really
exciting because
the new iphone obviously shoots hdr and
hdr 60 frames a second so now with this
apple tv 4k you'll be able to take full
advantage of that they also said that
there is an enhancement update for
airplay so that will also be able to
support those higher frame rates which
is something that i feel like i was kind
of struggling with i sometimes
feel like airplay is just not quite
there when you're streaming the content
from your phone so hopefully
this update will help alleviate a lot of
that this other thing that was
pretty awesome is color balancing your
tv
with your iphone and the apple tv will
use light sensors in your phone that
will compare your tv to standards
and it will automatically adjust the
output i think it's
cool that this is something that's kind
of coming to consumers because
when we were watching this keynote
tyler's like i spent like 250
on a monitor calibration tool and now
this is something
that everyone can just do right here at
home just be like
calibrated we're done another thing that
i was just like
shook they finally freaking updated
the apple tv remote i'm gonna be putting
a find my air tag
on this apple tv remote because for the
life of me
i still can't i don't know where any of
the remotes are like where do they go
they just like
disappear but they did completely
redesign
this remote it's now an all one piece
aluminum design
with a brand new click pad there's a
siri button on the side
you can use a circular gesture for jog
control it's all touch based and you can
order the remote separately the apple tv
4k is starting at 179 for the 32 gig
version and 199
for the 64 gig version all right so
this is where the hype train took off
when they announced the new imax
so these have been rumored so this is
really not like a huge surprise that
they announced an
m1 imac but they didn't just announce
one they announced
seven different colors it's 50
smaller 11.5 millimeters thin 24 inch
11.3 million pixel display it also has
an upgraded camera microphone
and speakers the front-facing facetime
hd camera
is now 1080p with a larger sensor and
image signal processing so what this is
doing is it's basically using ai to try
to improve your image i'm also very
excited about this upgraded microphone
because it will definitely cancel out
any other sounds in the house
so it's a beamforming microphone that's
basically focusing on you and they said
that this is
the best mic system ever in a mac so if
they say it
it's got to be true 85 faster graphics
than the previous 21 inch max
50 faster graphics 3x faster machine
processing
four usb c ports and this new power
connector it just
magnetically attaches to the imac in the
back then it has this braided cable that
will then go to your power brick which
will nicely sit on the ground
but what's cool about this is it
actually has an ethernet port
so if you want to plug in ethernet you
don't have to actually plug it into your
mac
you can plug it into this brick and
because of that little magsafe connector
that's transferring the data directly to
your imac so i'm very
excited about this so obviously the
highlight of all of this is these
are now m1 powered and with this m1 chip
this is giving the ability to basically
scale down the logic boards and make
everything so much smaller because of
the system on a chip technology
everything is now much more powerful and
smaller and compact
and way more energy efficient okay so
obviously there's new colors
and with these new colors my first
thought while i was looking at these i
was like but i want my keyboard to match
oh i want my mouse to match oh i want my
trackpad to match so there's three
variations of the keyboard they
obviously come in all of the colors
the magic keyboard now has keys for
spotlight dictation do not disturb an
emoji
and for the first time touch id
it's cool because it does come in the
smaller version they also have one with
the extended keyboard with a number pad
i'm a huge
number pad fan so i will definitely be
getting the number pad version i also
like that there's a lock button now on
the keyboard so if you want to quickly
lock your computer you can just be like
lock done this is me locking
my computer that's also me unlocking my
computer
with my fingerprint i love that they
have the mouse and the track pads to
match
mouse mice mice mousse
the colors match and the pink imac it
might have my name on it i don't know if
you can do engraving in this but if you
could
it would already come with my name on it
for sure so i'm on
the buy the all all-new 24-inch imac it
looks like there's three variations that
you can purchase
so the lowest version is the eight core
and the seven core and this does not
have
two usb 3 ports or the gigabit ethernet
so that's starting at 12.99 and that
only comes in four colors the blue green
pink and the silver and the other two
models are the eight core cpu and gpu
and at 14.99
that's your 256 because of storage and
then 512 is starting at 16.99 and these
have all of the colors the blue
green pink silver yellow orange
and purple it's interesting though
because they didn't do
like a space gray version so i feel like
they kind of want to save that
for the pro version to have that space
gray the matte black
it's gonna look good the train continues
on its way and now we're at the ipad pro
and why this is exciting that the m1 is
now coming to the ipad is that's going
to be so
incredibly powerful that it's going to
be almost overkill for most people that
are going to be needing this tablet
but for people who are doing
illustration video production design
real-time augmented reality whatever it
is that you're doing that is
processor intensive like this ipad is
more pro
than ever i mean i've seen the power
just in my own
experiences with this m1 and now that m1
going to the imac and now into the ipad
it's pretty exciting they showed a demo
of something that's really cool
is this ipad is now 5g enabled so it's
kind of going to be shifting the way i
think that a lot of us are creating or
consuming
i also love the frame i o got a shout
outs because i'm a huge fan of frame io
i use that for all of my storage needs
for transferring footage back and forth
for sending videos to clients for
feedback and they've been working on
some really cool camera to cloud
transfer so throwing this new ipad in
the mix
it's going to be game changing really so
the ipad pro has a 50
faster cpu 40 faster graphics i also
love that it has
next-gen controller compatibility so all
of the new next-gen consoles
like the new xbox and the playstation
those controllers will not work on the
ipad
it also has 2x faster storage and you
can configure this thing up to two
terabytes of storage which is
kind of mind-blowing i mean that's
doubling the storage of the previous
version
it also now has faster connectivity
because those usb-c
ports are now gonna support thunderbolt
and usb4 and it also supports the pro
display xtr at
full 6k resolution
what they did a big update to the
truedepth camera it's now ultra wide and
they have this feature called center
stage so when you're on one of your
facetime calls or whatever call it is
that you're doing i'm not sure if this
will carry over to zoom calls or
anything else
it'll keep you in the center frame but
here's the thing
it looks like the camera is only on
the top still because most of the time
when i'm using my ipad it's
in this sort of orientation so it would
make more sense
to have that camera in the center if it
is
yeah either way i like this center stage
feature and i think that's going to
definitely be something that's utilized
the display is something that is also
incredibly impressive they're calling
this the liquid
retina xdr display and the full screen
brightness
is a thousand but at peak brightness you
can get 1600 nits
which is pretty incredible it's crazy
because the starting price is very
close if not exactly the same as the
previous version the ipad pro 11 inch is
starting at 7.99 and the ipad pro 12.9
inch is starting at 10.99 and they also
have a new
white magic keyboard cover which i'm
very
very excited about really the main
takeaway from this is
this is a 5g enabled ipad which is kind
of huge especially if you're somebody
who
is traveling a lot or you need to be
constantly connected on your ipad
normally a lot of times you could just
get away with
using your phone as a hotspot the fact
that everything is there
color me impressed
well guys that was just sort of a quick
recap of what happened at the apple
event today my sister and i are also
going to be doing a podcast talking
about some of the things that we saw
today and discussing
all of our thoughts and reactions so be
sure to check that out youtube.com
samebrain or check out same brain on
apple podcasts or
anywhere that you listen to podcasts i
look forward to seeing you guys in my
next video
and stay tuned for some coverage on all
of these things i'll see you guys in the
next video
subscribe hit the bell leave a comment
let me know your thoughts
see you guys very very soon bye
[Music]
you